MSNBC host Chris Hayes sent a tweet over
the weekend that didn't make a lot of
sense and he's taking some heat for it
and I'll give you the backstory it
started when fusions Collier men derson
tweeted her displeasure with how a
Hasidic Jewish man was behaving next to
her on an airplane and I'll put up first
her tweet which says has a picture of
this Hasidic man saying you guys it's
happening to me the Hasidic dude on my
flight is asking every single man who
walks by to switch with me okay so the
backstory on this
Hasidic men are not supposed to have
physical contact with women that they
are not married to or their daughters or
family unmarried women I don't even know
exactly what the rule is but that's the
sort of gist of it
it makes absolutely no sense to me
however that's his religion but if
you're going to fly on a plane you might
have to sit next to a woman and this is
a known routine that happens with the
tiny percentage of the Jewish population
that is Hasidic they make a big sting
they can't sit next to a woman okay
makes absolutely no sense whatsoever
very very clear about that
in response Chris Hayes puts up a tweet
where he says perfect time to start a
good Frank BDS conversation of course
BDS referring to the movement to boycott
divest and divest from and sanction
Israel now at some point Chris Hayes
clearly realized that if this was a joke
it did not go over very well
deleted the tweet maybe thinking better
of it in some way he had a ton dozens
and dozens of responses from people and
a lot of people were saying rightfully
so what is a Jewish man of unknown
nationality on a flight have to do with
the boycott of one country in the Middle
East for the problems that one or
another person might have with the
foreign policy now some people said well
this is straight-up anti-semitic others
said it's anti Israeli some said it's
just flat-out stupid and Hayes was asked
about the accusations and said you know
what I was happy to delete the tweet
since outside of the context of the
back-and-forth that I was having with
this journalist I actually understand
why people found it offensive in the
he was asked well do you support the BDS
movement and he said I don't or at least
my views are muddy the subject of this
joke was my friends view on the issue
here's why this is concerning and it's
not really that Chris Hayes made the
joke if it's a joke
I give Chris Hayes the benefit of the
doubt fine it was a joke that out of
context could seem like hey wait wait a
second
why what does that have to do with a
single Hasidic guy it's that in spite of
it I'll admit being a joke countless
people online are saying this was
correct
you should be confronting the Hasidic
dude about the boycott divestment
sanction issue an Orthodox Jew from
somewhere in the world is annoying a
woman on a plane so the reaction is to
tell him about boycotting Israel this
may be an individual who had never been
to Israel and I'll go even further this
could have been although it didn't
appear to be can you put that first the
picture of the guy back up I just want
to take one more look at it
yeah based on the fact that he's not
wearing a particular hat it doesn't seem
that he is a Satmar Hasidic Jew who
often are more anti Israeli but he might
have taken the hat off for the flight
who knows the point is this is sort of
like when Jewish reggae singer modest
Yahoo was told he can only play at a
festival in Spain called roto Tom if he
makes some kind of disclaimer that he is
against certain Israeli policies talk
about a Jew from New York all right I
think matisyahu's from White Plains and
or somewhere around there it is a
standard that would never be applied
elsewhere and think for example a Muslim
woman going through TSA security she's
refusing to take off her face covering
maybe because it violates her religion
to be in public without it that's a
really great time to talk to her about
the atrocities being committed by the
wah wah hobbyists in Saudi Arabia
nobody would apply that standard would
they Jason I hope not
the one thing that I wonder about is say
you're like me I had no idea that they
had this kind of rule law whatever it is
yeah so what if you're some random woman
on a plane yeah and the Jewish man next
you refuses to sit next to you and you
don't know any you have no reason why
yeah
think about the internal conflict
sure sure but you don't have to do
anything you're in your seat if some
dude doesn't want to sit next to you
that's his problem if the airline is
going to allow it or Norton or not
that's sort of their problem but it
would not it should not trigger the
thought of and it didn't in this in this
journalist right this was Chris Hayes
tweeting it of saying now I should talk
to this dude about Israeli foreign
policy and how I want to boycott it not
a standard that would be applied in any
other scenario that I can think of